a constructive and welcome step was how
the u.s described the first day
of indirect talks with iran officials
from five world powers
russia china germany france and britain
met with iran at austria's grand vienna
hotel
european officials have been shuttling
between there and the imperial hotel
across the road
where u.s officials are staying they're
attempting
to bring the u.s back to the 2015
nuclear deal
they'd signed with iran we do see this
as a constructive
and certainly welcome step and in the
end
we hope that we are able to
leave vienna return to united states our
negotiating team i should say with a
better understanding
of a road map for how we get to that end
state
mutual compliance donald trump described
the 2015 agreement as
the worst deal in history and pulled out
in 2018
trump had then reimposed u.n sanctions
with additional u.s sanctions on tehran
in february biden rescinded un sanctions
but he hasn't gone as far as lifting u.s
sanctions
saying they'll only happen once iran is
compliant with the 2015 nuclear deal
since then iran has been violating the
terms of the deal
and was reported to have reached 12
times the levels permitted
of enriched uranium stockpile but iran
now also agrees
negotiations are on the right path
we find this position realistic and
promising it could be the start of
correcting the bad process that has
taken diplomacy to a dead end
we welcome these comments not long
after tuesday's vienna meeting had
concluded there were reports that an
iranian ship was damaged by a mine in
the red sea
state media says the vessel was
supporting iranian commando
sent to escort commercial ships it's
hard to
uh consider this a coincidence maybe it
is but you know the good news is that
the entire world
supports a return to the nuclear deal by
the us and iran
with a couple of notable exceptions um
and i think the israelis
uh the saudis and the emiratis and then
congressional republicans
are the the parties who are the vast
minority
but who do not want a deal and are going
to do everything possible to try to
upset this process for now it seems
clear
that the administrations in both tehran
and washington
are keen to try to get a rocky
relationship back on track
laura about manly al jazeera